all the learning and all the growth is
in the slip UPS now that's but when
you're like I'm just speaking as an
alcoholic they're shrouded in so much
shame yeah you know they're horrible
yeah there's pain in there and at the
time it's gonna hurt right but if you
embrace it and if you're prepared for it
in many ways so it's not something that
we actively encourage but we sort of
slip it in there subtly because we lose
too many people that will come along do
a challenge brilliantly well to day 20
slip up and dispit and go I fell that's
it and I think when you're aimed in that
middle ground so we're not aimed at the
dependent you know you can say to those
people look don't use that as an excuse
to give up so you must slip it in we
slip it into some of the work that we do
for the videos or the emails so it's in
the back of their mind that actually
they might slip up and if they do
there's great learning in there and it's
going to hurt and you're going to feel
like you've failed and you've messed up
but there's so much growth in there
because as you said you can find out
ways to not slip up in the future and
suddenly then you do 30 days or 40 days
or 90 days and the whole world looks a
lot different